yo what is up everybody this procedure
man 3g here with another Borderlands the
pre-sequel video and so if you haven't
heard Borderlands and gearbox are at PAX
south which is going on right now as i'm
recording this is the last day of pack
south this is sunday january twenty
fifth and gearbox has officially
announced the third DLC of Borderlands
the pre-sequel the second DLC character
and it is a really of the barrenness if
you haven't heard lady lady oh really a
the bareness because she feels better
actually lady hammerlock ananka's yeah
since hammerlock his last name and yeah
if you didn't know that's hammerlock
sister so this is gonna be a quick video
I'm going to be telling you guys a
little bit about her just to show if you
guys haven't heard about it's not even
post any videos about it but I know
other people doing boiling zzzquil stuff
on YouTube have so I'm just gonna make
sure you guys know about her and yeah so
the gameplay just some me killing things
so enjoy alright so as we know the only
thing that really is different about a
different character is the action scale
and the skill trees so her action skill
is called cold as ice it lets her throw
out a frost diadem shard that seeks out
enemies and attaches to them dealing
constant damage if that target dies the
shard will move on to a new enemy and so
on so the charm go out it'll be crying
enemies you shoot them up they die it
goes to another enemy and starts crying
there so that's pretty good she is based
on cry damage she is a cryo damager
person and so her skill trees are
Huntress cold money and contractual
aristocracy sorry I had a little trouble
that so the Huntress Kree Huntress skill
tree focuses on sniping it includes the
skills such as ones that offer large
critical hit bonuses for each
consecutive hit you land without missing
the cold money skill tree focuses on ice
damage and includes us and like the
final skill is a skill that will add cry
of damage
to any gun that you have the description
of the skill is called wintertide to
kill skill upon killing an enemy all
your non cry of guns deal cry of damage
along with their normal elemental type
or no element if they don't have an
elemental site and causes cryo damage
crowd with guns doing more crowd damage
twenty-five percent more crowd damage so
this this is really good since cry was
the way to do more damage enemies to say
you have a shock weapon this will now do
cryo and shock so you can kill enemies
even faster and lastly her third skill
tree which I had trouble saying before
the contractual aristocracy skill tree
allows her to turn one of your co-op
teammates into a more or less servant
which earns her bonuses for the kills
that they get in addition to the kill
that she gets so she will be released
this Tuesday January the 27th for
everyone to play if you have the season
passed she's including the season pass
if you don't have the season pass she's
gonna be ten bucks like all the dlc have
been so far uh that's basically about it
i'm not going to do a full skill tree
analysis since that it's just gonna be
really long and I I think it'll be
better for you guys to get it you guys
to learn all the skills yourselves i'll
probably make a skill tree video for her
if i cut if i get a good build i want
i'll probably do a fur kind of first
impressions on her skill tree and if i
have fun then i'll just post a lot of
videos about her yeah so also gearbox
might be announcing something about
borderlines 3 at this packs so if that
that comes up you'll see another video
for me so I guys hope you've enjoyed
this quick little snippet of a really of
the barrenness the new dlc and make sure
you check out my channel for other
boorlands the pre-sequel stuff since i
had to have a ton of content on that and
i'll see you all later peace out guys